hi my name is Lamia user and this is my
MSX story when I first came to Stanford
I found out that I can volunteer to be
part of interdisciplinary classes
between the business school and
different other departments on campus
because I'm a computer scientist I
wanted to be part of the
interdisciplinary research between
business school and the computer science
department so I volunteered for this
class that was offered for the first
time at GSB on AI and machine learning
for business leaders in this class we
put together professors from the
business school and professors from the
computer science department in order to
bring together the knowledge of what
does it mean for AI at the discipline in
the business realm as well as at the
field at the research field one funny
story that came from this class is in
the first session when we were
introducing robotics and AI concepts the
first impression of the students was
robotics are going to take over the
world
it's a terminator kind of story it's
going to take over everything quickly
through the class we saw the change in
the perception of the students and they
are changing from the terminator story
to visiting the robotics lab here at
Stanford and seeing how the robotics
field is not as advanced as we thought
the most advanced robot that we have
here in Stanford which is one of the
most advanced in the world couldn't
climb stairs couldn't open doors and can
hardly communicate their emotions or
feelings the students came back and say
that's cute where did the Terminator
story come from and that was a change in
perception and more grounded truth into
where the field is whether from a
computer science point of view or from a
business point of view